So this is a new topic called the
physics of dynamics of rigid bodies,
so did did body is something
that will not bend,
will not change its shape
when you apply forces to it,
and one example could be a
dime or coin or neither stick.
Of course, nobody's absolutely
rigid. You can always bend anything,
but we'll take the approximation
that we have in our hands,
a completely rigid body.
The technical definition of a rigid body
is that if you pick a couple of points,
the distance between them does not
change during the motion of the body.
So the dynamics of rigid bodies in
three dimensions is fairly complicated
because what I want you to
imagine now is not a point mass,
but some object with
some shape like this guy,
take this and throw it up in the air.
You can see it does
something fairly complicated.
In fact,
we can characterize what it
does using two expressions.
I think you can guess what they are.
One is if this had been a
point mass than the point mass,
we'll just go back and
forth that up and down.
It will do what's called translations.
It will go from a place to another place,
maybe on a straight line, maybe on a
curve, but as it goes, the point masters,
no further information. We got to tell
me where it is and how fast it's moving.
That's the whole story.
But if you have a body like this,
it's not enough to tell me where it is
because if I throw this up in the air,
you can imagine that asset
travels along some parabolic path.
One instant it is,
it may look like this next instant
it isn't may look like this.
So we say that it is
translating and rotating.
It's a non obvious theorem that anything
the body does from one instance to the
next instant can be achieved by first
translating it than doing a slight,
slight rotation to bring it to the
configuration you want. In other words,
you can go from here to here by a
translation followed way rotation.
Now translation is what we've been
studying all the time because four point
particles, there is no
notion of retention. I take
a point mass and rotated.
You don't even know. It's rotating
data's no internal variables.
So that was the problem we've
been focusing on, but not,
we're going to enlarge over to study
two objects which have a size and which
have a shape.
That's what we are to have an orientation.
It's not enough to say the football
is here, who ball could be here,
but as long pointy and could
be up to Donner site to site.
So what we want to do is to
break the problem into two parts.
We want to focus on a body which
only rotating but not translating.
Once we sharpened our skills,
we will then put back the
ability of the body to translate.
So they're going to focus initially
on a body that cannot translate.
So what that means is you take the
body and you grabbed one point in it,
then you can ask what can it do?
If I grabbed one point and well,
any motion it does,
we'd be set at that point is not moving.
Now in three dimensions.
If you take a football and at
certain point is held fixed,
it can generate in many ways.
But at any instant you can show what it
would be doing is to be doing a rotation
out on an access passing through the point
where you're grabbing it because the,
if it rotates through an access points
on the axis don't move and the point
where to grabbing it better lie on that
axis. Now that's also pretty complicated.
You can see why I gave you a little
precautionary thing because it's hard to
visualize these things. So again, I want
to take the simplest possible problem,
then make it more and more complex.
Now you might say the simplest thing
you've been doing all semester long is to
take things in one dimension,
but that turns out to be too low.
If you've got any one dimension and
you've got a rigid body by a bit,
rigid body means not only extended
but actually rigid. For example,
if you take a cat or a snake,
a snake,
you can grab at one point or the snake
is not simply doing rotations around the
one point right?
Trying to bite you,
trying to move around because
steak is not a rigid body.
That's Nate could be rigid body living,
snake, definitely not ready to buy it.
Now you got to remember that I've given
you a break by studying rigid bodies,
but real bodies,
uh,
can actually not only
wobble and twist and turn,
they can also vibrate and they
can move their arms around.
That's much more difficult.
So we won't go there and we will
try to take the simplest rigid body.
But I said if I take a
rigid body in one dimension,
it cannot rotate at all because there's
not room in one dimension to rotate.
It can only go back and forth.
So to show you that as
some new possibility,
I have to go at least two dimensions.
Here's one example where
one dimension is not enough.
So I'm going to imagine rigid bodies
which are living in the plane of the
blackboard.
Now one way to do that is to take a
piece of battle, just cut out a shape
that's a rigid body.
Now of course this has a slight thickness
because anything you make of matter
and has some thickness
at please one atom thick.
But imagine that thickness is negligible.
So it's like a piece of metal
piece of foil or something,
but it's rigid and this is the rigid body.
We are going to study.
This rigid body can move in the
plane of the blackboard and rotate,
but we're going to grab it at one point.
So let's pick some point here.
If I grabbed it at that point and I
asked you what can this fellow do you
imagine skewer didn't get through
the blackboard. You say, okay,
do whatever you want.
You realize that all it can do is to
rotate around an axis penetrating that
point.
So let's say a Tig weld the zero,
the body look like this a little later,
it's going to look rotated.
I have to tell you what it
is doing at a given instance.
I have to tell you how each audience,
so what we do for that is we draw
through the point of rotation.
Some line you can pick any line you like,
pick a line like that and we'd say what
angle that line makes with the standard
Joyson direction.
Usually the x axis
fake give you a data. I think you have
to think about it and you have to agree.
I've told you where the bodies, you
can reconstruct everything, right?
Because that point is nailed. It
cannot move. You take the body,
you're trying to buy an angle data.
In other words, here is a question.
Suppose you're not in this room.
You go to another room and I want to
tell you what did they did body is doing?
What information do I have to communicate
to you without seeing the picture I
claim if I tell you how the
line was drawn in the body,
which is something you do
once and for all ruled line,
then I say the rural line makes
an angle data with the exact axis.
I believe you can imagine in another room
what his body is doing and that's the
meaning of saying I've given
complete information. Of course,
that's not a complete
dynamical information because
it also depends on how fast
is rotating,
but to simply say the analog of where the
body is in one dimension is this angle
data.
So what we're going to set up,
you will find is an analogy between
one dimensional translation and two
dimensional rotations.
You'll find the analogy is very helpful.
So I'm going to use the piece of the
blackboard where I'll keep drawing that
analogy.
I do this because the number
of things you have to remember,
it would be reduced if you map this
problem mathematically to the problem with
translation. One dimension, in
other words, in one dimension,
when a body is moving,
x tells you where did this right?
I give you a number three,
a Pi or minus 14 you know where it is for
this rigid body living in the plane of
the blackboard is angled.
Data tells you
what the body's doing. So even
though the body is in two dimensions,
you need this one angle data to
tell you what is orientations.
You don't need two numbers.
A single number tells you
what the digit bodies doing,
so a little later it could be
rotated by an angle. Delta data.
That's the analog of seeing it
move from x to x Plus Delta X.
First thing you've got to do is how
do you want to measure data for x?
We know we have agreed we're
going to measured in meters data.
The standard preference for people at
elementary stages system measured in
degrees. You measured in degrees and when
the body complete one full revolution,
you like to say, let's turn by
an angle of three 60 degrees.
Now that is not the preferred
way to measure angles.
In more advanced dynamics,
we're going to use something else.
You can imagine what it is.
You know what I'm driving at in
nobody know where I'm going. Radium.
So I'm going towards radiants
and you can ask yourself,
why would anybody think of a radiant?
What's wrong with three 60 degrees?
I mean all the textbooks, I mean
all the novels say, you know,
I was going down the wrong
path than I did a one 80 right?
So everyone knows.
Like I saw a book by a violinist who said
I was going down all the wrong things.
Then I did a three 60 so you
realize that three 60 years,
not really weird way to reform your life,
but I'm on the physicist.
It struck a chord in physics or three
60 is really not a trivial thing to do.
It turns out the particles in the world
that divided into Bose arms and fermions
and half of the particles or bosons and
roughly half affirming of electron is a
fermion.
The light quantum boys on and set for
trial for all the guys who are photons are
bosons. If you turn them by three 60
they come back to what they are doing.
Electronic turns out when you turn it
by three 60 all the numbers going into
minus those numbers and only when you
turned by seven 20 you come back to
technically what you're doing.
So it's quite possible this
person had in mind the behavior.
Maybe she was from [inaudible]
but that's what it said.
I did a three 60 but I've
got the three 60 many times.
So if you use it you better back it up
with the kind of information that gave.
Otherwise you just off by a factor of two.
Anyway,
ThreeSixty is very nice.
I think the Babylonians like three 60 for
lot of reasons is divisible by a whole
bunch of numbers that are easy to
partition into smaller and smaller pieces.
I believe in some engineering circles,
a circle is 400 something else,
some other engineering degrees.
So you can decide what a circle is,
but we like a radiant.
So let's ask,
why do we like it radio for that purpose.
I want you to take a point here at a
distance r from the center and let it move
to a new location with
an angle Delta Theta.
You agree that if the
rigid body is rotating,
this guy will be traversing a circle of
radius art because it's a rigid body.
It cannot change the
distance from this point.
So we'll be going around in a circle and
I'm asking you how big is that segment
that are clanked delta that it
has traveled when it was rotated?
Ben Angle Delta data.
So one way to calculate that is to
say, look, if I did a full circle,
I would have done to pay our
artists the distance of this point.
In that I did body from the
center [inaudible] listen
to two Pi r but I've Gone
Delta Theta.
So the fraction of the circle I have
covered you still today over three 60
if data is measured in degrees,
so let me indicate that in this fashion
so we can write this ass Pi over one 80
Delta Theta
claims are
if you measured data and degrees,
this is what you have to do to convert
an angular Trevor's to an actual distance
along the kind into the circle,
the linear distance you travel,
it's connected with the angle by which
you rotate by the distance r from the
center. And this number
here. So people say, look,
why don't we make life easy
by calling data at times,
Pi would one 80 as a new angle.
Let's call it Delta Theta fines are
so Delta Theta without any little zero
on top of it stands for radiants from no
one and related to favor,
he thought the deltas data itself is
data in degrees times Pi over one 80
then the advantages, the distance
you travel, linear distance,
you travel better.
Simple relations.
The angle you travel by the
arm length are from the center
so you don't have to carry this
one 80 and pie and everything.
You can write the simple design
but now when you do this,
you are measuring it in radio. So you've
got to have an idea. How big is it radio?
Well a full circle.
If you go full circle,
the distance you travel should be to PR.
So full circle we'll be
Delta Theta equals two Pi.
So your circle is worth two Pi Radians
to pious like six so one radians roughly
one six to three 60 which is 60 degrees.
The real answer is close
to 58 something degrees.
It looks like an odd thing to pick.
It's odd only if you start
with three 60 degrees,
but if you met people
from an alien culture,
he's just got to go to the
supermarket around. Did these people,
those people may not be
using three 60 at all.
Three 60 is a human artifact.
Nothing special about three 60 that's
independent of our own cultural biases.
Baby connected.
How many fingers we have to maybe
connect to how long a year is and so on.
There's nothing natural about the
number two 62 Pi. On the other hand,
I believe would be discovered
Baney advanced civilization.
If you haven't figured out Pie,
you're not advanced civilization.
If you haven't figured out too,
you're way behind them so you're not too
and you know pie and that's what other
cultures in other planets and
galaxies would it be using.
That's the unit we like to use.
You'll find over and over people
using units which are natural to us,
but later on if you want to communicate
with people in another planet,
you will have to use different links.
For example,
the height of a human are the
length of Napoleon's army.
They're not very good units. If you don't
have an airport in, in your background,
you don't know what you're talking about,
but if you mentioned distances in how
big it is in terms of an hydrogen atom,
hydrogen atoms all over the universe,
that's the natural length scale to use.
This is a very popular issue.
In the old days when they sent off a
rocket or the buried something underground
for aliens to find out,
you want to show how tall we are.
No use giving the answered in
meters or feet or anything,
but if we can somehow relate your
size the size of a hydrogen atom,
then that number will make sense to people
in all civilizations because hydrogen
atoms conveniently are manufactured and
scattered all over the universe and they
have the same size. Okay. Anyway,
that's a long thing about ratings.
That's why we like to use radios.
You have to know a few popular angles
and radiant measure because I'll be using
only radiants most of the time you got
to know a circle is two pi by user,
half a circle and Pi over
two is quarter circle,
so when you turn by 90 degrees is Pi over
two is that something you should know
once you write it this way, let's get
another result. That's very useful.
Take the distance of travels along the
tangents by the time over which it does
that
this,
it's the actual pageant,
some speed or the magnitude of the
velocity in the tangential direction.
I think you all agree with that.
That's what you and I would mean by
speed if other instant this piece of the
sample just broke and flew off,
it'll keep flying. Would that speed
this thing?
We have a symbol for it. Omega three and
Omega is called the angular velocity.
Okay,
and is measured in Radians per second
so you cannot, you can calculate and
good velocity for various things.
For example, what's the angular velocity
of the moon as it goes around the earth?
Well, angular velocity will be one
revolution every 28 days, right?
One Revolution is two Pi Radians at 28
days you do 28 times 24 times 3,600 if
that many radians per second,
oh that's a chain saw blade and the chain
size spinning at some number of Rpm,
maybe 3000 rpm.
You can take revolutions per minute.
Two revolutions per second.
What you've got to remember,
every revolution is two Pi Radians.
So the angle of velocity off of blade,
that spinning with
frequency F is two Pi f.
You understand that f is the
number of complete revolutions?
It does definitely pick a point on it.
It does at travelers of 2.5 radians.
So the dictionary has
got a second member here,
which is the velocity,
which is DXDT.
There's no the place, the angular
velocity, which is de, De, de, De, de.
This is an analogy by the way,
this is to help you say omega is like
what velocity used to be in the old days
when things are moving back and forth,
but no, they're going round and round.
But even here,
there's the notion of velocity,
what is not in meters per second
as measured in Radians per second.
Now here is something that you guys
got to keep very clear in your head.
I can only mention it to you
but I cannot do it for you.
This Omega is an analogous
thing to ordinary velocity,
but that is also an actual velocity here.
The good old velocity,
that's the tangential velocity of points
with that part of a rotating the dead
body. That is not part of my dictionary,
but it's a very useful result to know.
The tangential velocity is the angle
of velocity times the distance of that
point from the center of the rotation.
So the rigid body as a whole has a single,
I ain't got a velocity.
That's what it means to be redone.
The whole thing is rotating.
You cannot say the angle of velocity
so and so here and so and so there.
It's the property of the entire
body for the linear velocity.
It's not the same everywhere points and
yet here in the same time go that far
and points and yet he hadn't the same
time go that far for the linear velocity
increases from the center of the time.
The angular velocity is constant and
it's a rigid body cannot have to angular
velocities. It's going to have only
one angle over the last year. Okay.
Then what we do is we say,
okay,
let's take a problem with the
angular velocity is itself changing.
Fine.
That's the analog of saying,
let us have an agent of change of velocity
and here we have a quantity called
Alpha,
which is the rate of change of I ain't
going to velocity or the second rate of
change of the angle,
and that's been noted by Alpha.
So if you took a team,
if you took one of these rotating circular
saws and it was spinning at a certain
speed and due to friction, let
us see the slowing down. I'd,
when you turn on the motor speeding up,
suppose he just turned on the saw
motor and it's speeding up in the,
in his rotation.
You've got to be very clear
that the acceleration of
that of parts, this is the,
this is the saw blade. Okay. This I'm
trying to draw for you. One of these uh,
saw blades and it's spinning. If you
pick up points they on the circumference,
you remember long back we learned even
if it's going at a constant speed,
constant angular speed,
it has a tangential velocity which is
Omega Times are and because of that it'll
have an acceleration towards the center
centripetal acceleration which is v
squared over r and you can
write it as Omega squared,
r squared over r Omega squared off.
That's one acceleration. It has. Even
if we're spinning at a steady rate,
but I'm saying it can also have a
tangential acceleration if on top of
everything else the angular
speed itself is changing.
Let's take our time digesting that.
This is not too hard,
but I want you guys to understand
if it's spinning at a steady omega,
we have learned anything going in.
A circle has an old fashioned linear
acceleration toward the center,
which is v squared over R,
but we have realized V in the Tangential
Directions Omega are so if you put that
in,
do you want,
you can call it be tangential that
gives me Omega squared r that just the v
squared over r but if you put the brakes
on this by speeding up or slowing down,
it'll have an addition,
an acceleration in this FedEx,
so an acceleration of a point on the
edge at anywhere else can have two
components.
The tangent should want it to be that
only if you speed up or slow down the
rotating disk, but the radio one will
always be there as long as it's rotating.
Okay.
Once you've got this dictionary new
can have a whole bunch of analogous
quantities.
What example,
if you focus on problems
where the body is,
has a constant angular acceleration alpha,
what can you say where you can already
say that data would be the theta?
Not less initial angle of velocity
plus one half hour 50 square.
This is because data is behaving just like
x. If x had a constant acceleration, a,
we all knew x was equal to the starting
x plus initial velocity times time plus
one half 80 square.
Similarly,
the angle by which it rotates
will be the initial angle,
initial angle of velocity time
plus something involving p square.
This is only if alpha is a constant.
This lake,
I hope you guys know this is true.
Only if ace account.
All right, now I'm going to
pursue the analogy and ask
what is the kinetic energy offered?
We did body
winter's rotate.
Yes.
Yeah.
Acceleration with Alpha here.
Um, right next to the salt lake. Oh, here.
Uh Oh. Up this one. Yeah.
I'm saying if you have a rotating disk,
take any point on rotating disk.
Even if the disc is going at
constant angular velocity,
it has a tangential velocity and the
direction of the velocity is constantly
changing.
This is the oldest thing we learned,
so it has an acceleration
towards the center that is
not an angular acceleration.
It's just a standard acceleration
toward the center of anything going in a
circle that's always going to be there,
but on top of it,
if you speed up or slow down
the rotation rate of the disk,
you'll also have a tangential
acceleration, which is alpha times the
are
not clear yet.
That's the acceleration
lay people would know.
If you're on a rotating platform and
somebody sped up the rotation rate,
you will notice you're going faster.
That's the acceleration,
the tangential direction,
the acceleration towards the
center is a more sophisticated one.
We have learned and it's due to the
fact that velocity is a vector and auto
scaler, so the direction is
changing. There's an acceleration.
We associated with that and it as
real as any other acceleration.
It needs a force to make it happen.
Maybe the better way to ask you is this.
Suppose this little Spec here is you,
okay,
you happen to be stuck on a rotating
chainsaw blade and you're clinging to it
for dear life.
What force do you have to apply
to stay on for the rotating blade?
This may not happen to you and me,
but you know, fuel, organized crime.
This is not a very unusual situation.
Uh,
you can find yourself intermingled with
all kinds of machinery and you want to
know what do I do to stay on?
Well, Newton tells you the answer.
You wouldn't say this. If you want to
be on this rotating chainsaw blade,
your acceleration toward the
center has to be paid for.
And if the blade is speaking of speed,
that's gotta be paid for two.
That's the net acceleration.
That time is your mass will be the
force that has to be applied to you.
So you will cling on to it with that
force and that force will be applied in
turn by the third law,
by the disk on you.
For example. Suppose it's a top
view of a rotating platform.
You're just standing there and the
platform is rotating. You can ask,
what force does it,
what frictional force does it need?
Do I need to stay on the platform?
Well,
you need the force to provide you
with a man. And I'm telling you,
you're a has two parts. Even if the merry
go down the spinning at a steady rate,
you will need to have a friction force
director towards the center to bend you
into a circle and if on top of it the
merry go round starts increasing its speed
or decreasing its speed, you'll also
needed tangential component of force.
Probably the tangential acceleration.
Okay.
Now this is kinematics off rotation
at constant angular acceleration.
It's identical to this one mathematically
because mathematically if you know
lead to data,
d d squared is alpha.
The answer is just like d two
x over d squared equals ae.
You changed the symbols.
You get the same answer.
You can imagine a variety of
problems I don't feel like doing.
I think you guys can easily do that.
I'd rather focus on more difficult ones.
But example,
a chain saw blade spinning at 3,600
RPM is decelerated or some rate alpha.
How long does it take to come to the rest?
Well for that you will like
the second formula or Megan,
he comes Omega Zero Plus Alpha t.
That's the analog of v Equals v zero
plus 80 and you start with some Omega,
not you put on the brakes.
Alpha will be some negative number.
You see at what time does Omega goes
to zero. That's when it'll stop.
Now that result,
which I will use today,
in fact it's the following or mega square
is Omegas zero square plus two alpha
it a minus state or not.
That's the analog of B
squared Equals v Zero Square.
Let's do a x minus x.
Now
this is if the body has an acceleration
alpha, then it's going to speak up speed.
Of course in the final speed square is
related initial angle of velocity squared
plus two times the acceleration
times the angle rotated.
So this is the analogy, so we don't
have to reinvent all of these things.
They just come from the fact that things
which are mathematically the same have
the same mathematical results
will be the same equation.
They were the same results.
All right,
now let's find the Kennedy
Energy author. Rigid body, it's,
it's got mass and if we're spinning all
the little atoms making up the body are
moving.
They got their own one half MV squared
and we wanted to ask what does the total
one, half MV squared, some Dover,
all the particles for that purpose.
It's convenient to take the
following simple. A rigid body
were taken into the body by taking
[inaudible] and one at that.
This is auto one connected to some
central hub with the massless rod and you
take another mass and
you'd take a third mass.
This is m two senators,
an art to this AME three at a distance,
r three and so on.
You can make a rigid body by
modeling it in a simple fashion.
If you are a little more abstract,
you can take a continuous rigid
body and do the same thing,
but let's start with the simple thing.
Here's the rigid body,
three rigid rods with mass as m one m
two and three and it's nailed here and
that is a skewer going through the board
and things can only rotate around that.
By the way,
I should tell you the convention for Omega
in one dimensional motion velocity is
positive.
You're moving to the right and negative
here and moving to the left with angular
velocity, we got to have a convention
on what's positive and what's negative.
This thing with the spinning can only
spend clockwise or counterclockwise.
It turns out to be that Omega is
positive for counterclockwise.
That just happens to be the kind
of mentioned people use. In fact,
you notice the way I drew the rigid
body when I did Delta Theta had rotating
counterclockwise.
That's the preferred direction for
measuring the angle theta from the x axis.
Okay?
Now let's take this rigid body.
It is rotating with a
common angular velocity.
I hope you all understand that
the meaning of being graded,
everybody's got the same
angle of Velocity Omega,
so what's the kinetic
energy of this object
is the kinetic energy of each
mass summed over all the masses.
I M I v I square.
Now,
what's the velocity of each object?
If you dig this body and one it's the
last day is necessarily perpendicular to
the line. Joining it to the point of
rotation. This one is moving this way.
It cannot move in the line joining it
because if it is, it's not a rigid body,
rigid body. All distances are maintained
so you don't come near the center,
you don't go far from the center, so all
you can do is rotate around the center.
So the velocity of this Guy v one is equal
to Omega Times are one the last year.
This Guy v two it's the same
Omega Times are too so on.
So you can then add it all
up and what do you get?
You get one half some overt I
m I r I square omega squared
and you have to do the summation
over all the bodies. In my example,
summation goes from one to three. You may
have one to infinity. I want a million.
It doesn't matter.
That's the kinetic energy.
You guys follow this.
This is not a new candidate energy.
This is what we know to be kinetic energy.
Just one half MV where for every
piece that makes up the rigid body for
convenience,
I've taken that he did body to be
made up of a discrete set of masses,
but Navea notice as you go from one to
three m one and m two and m three at
three different numbers.
We don't know what the masses are are
when an art to an r three or three
different numbers.
We don't know how each one could be at
a different business from the origin,
but the Omega doesn't have a subscript
I that nothing called Omega for this one
and we'll make up for that one.
There's only one Omega for everything
so you can pull it out of the sun and
write it this way.
Okay.
Then the answer we write
as identical to one half,
I let me a square
and be given this ina I is
called the moment of an issue.
Yeah,
so continuing with the analogy,
this board is going to be as fun analogy.
We used to have k equal
to one half MV squared,
yet we are going to have k equal
to one half I omega squared
and I is called the moment of an issue.
So the moment of inertia is determined
not only by the masses that make up the
body,
but how far they are from the center.
If all the massive just fell on top of
the center of the body would have no
moment of inertia, it'll weigh the same
moment of inertia would vanish. Likewise,
if the massive spread out
[inaudible] she is more. For example,
if I'm standing around here and you
come along and decide to spin me,
I'm standing like this, we try to
spin me for sticking my hand sewed.
My moment of inertia has changed because
some of my mass now is further away
from the axis of rotation.
So one metal finish year depends
on the arrangement of the masses.
We're taking a rigid body,
not like ice dancers who do this with
talking about a rigid body. Therefore,
men of inertia is constant.
Okay?
But it requires a calculation
to find the moment of inertia.
And here's another important thing.
If I decide to rotate the body about
a new location, say around this point,
want me to finish, it will change because
all the distances are really changed.
The moment of finesse. Yet if
someone says, here are the masses,
here's where they are, please find me.
The moment I finish it, you will say,
I cannot do it.
You want to say I cannot do
it till you tell me the point.
Our own which you plan to rotate the body.
Unless that is given.
I cannot tell you what
the moment of inertia is.
That for the moment of
Venetia is with respect to
a point.
There's nothing called the
mass with respect to the point,
the massive just the mass Mormon
definition. It depends on the point.
I don't know which your computing,
the moment of a nation,
it's a video is also worth knowing that
if the body is being rotated about mass
m three than empty doesn't
contribute to momentum.
Financial aid's out anything sitting on
the axis doesn't contribute things for
the further away, contribute more in
proportion to their mass and proportion.
The square of the distance from the axis.
So this is my dictionary here.
So who is playing the role of mass?
Mass is played very moment of inertia.
It's got units of kilogram meters square
and no one has given a name for that.
What example? Newton Times meter
is called a Jew. You can ask.
No, this is kilograms times, meters
square. Maybe it's named after somebody.
So far it's not be named after anybody
or did they just call Newton meters
square?
So this is going to be
the analog off mass,
you know world of rotations.
You remember in the world of rotation
we defined something called momentum is
mass times velocity.
Here they're going to set up a call,
something called angular.
Momentum is going to be I times omega.
This I is called the angular momentum.
One extremely important point that
you guys should notice is that all the
concepts I'm using like mass and energy,
they are the same old concepts
that we learned earlier on.
The fact that it's rotating body
doesn't change anything. Okay?
Kennedy again are they
still means the same.
This k though it looks so different is
in fact the one happened B squared of
every part of the body. Some
dough with the bodies. All right,
so this l is called angular. Momentum
will take a while to get used to this,
but right now it's the product of the
moment of inertia. Angular velocity,
so now we are looking for the most
important equation in mechanics,
which is f equals m a
that's going to be equal
to some mystery object.
Now you should be able to guess what
goes on the right hand side. Okay?
You should know by now by analogy.
It can be written as d l d t v like
rate of change of momentum or it can be
written as i-times alpha.
It doesn't matter.
I hope you understand that
if a take rate of change,
the momentum you want to get mad because
when you take the bit of it to Amazon
are changing.
Likewise here,
if you take the l d t I is not changing
Omegas changing to give you what do you
make a DDS?
Alf,
I is not changing because as the body
rotates of coarse particles in the body
and moving around,
but that at a distance from the
point of rotation is not changing.
Even though the bodies and
moving to new locations,
the odd squared is the same
because they're just rotating.
That's why the in the
time that it would do,
you don't have to take the time that
it would do at the moment of inertia,
but we don't know who's going to
play the role on the left hand side.
Okay, so we had to go to find that are
going to find out the analog of that.
So I'm going to tell you there
are many ways to find this out.
It's a lot more subtle than generally
appreciate it on what the correct lies.
You can hit the last stated quite often,
but some of the reasonings behind it are.
So let me tell you one
way to get to the law.
I hope you know what I'm looking at.
I'm trying to find out what is the entity
that is responsible for the rate of
change of angular momentum or what's
the analog of the lefthand side for m a,
I know the right hand side is I am for
by analogy who is on the left hand side.
First of all,
it's pretty clear that if you want the
angular momentum of the body to change,
Omega has to change.
You can see if something is
spinning around at some fixed Omega,
you want to change it, you've got
to push up Buhler, do something.
So obviously going to play a force,
but the thing that comes to the left
hand side is not simply the force but
something else and we'll find out what
the something is and that's done by the
following device.
I'm going to use the good old work energy
theorem that says when force acts on
the body,
the work that it does,
okay,
which is the force times the distance
it travels is equal to the change in the
kinetic energy.
That is the standard work
in a DTM that we establish.
So if you took a rigid body like this
and let's apply it to the rigid body,
I'm just going to take a simple case
of rigid body with this two masses,
m two and m one it doesn't matter.
I apply a force now f perpendicular to
the body at the distance r from the point
of rotation
and let it turn the body during that time.
Uh,
let's say the body moves
when I'm on Delta data,
maybe I should draw you a better
picture for this because this is very,
very important.
So he had us the body,
I just took a simplest one with
two masses and one and two.
I'm just going to push it here and I
decided to push it in this direction and
it's half the distance r
from the point of rotation
and let it turn by a small
angle and come to this position.
This angle is delta data.
What does the work done by this force?
Okay,
I am going to write it down, but I want
you to think about it work that way.
The force is the force multiplier for
the distance over which it has moved.
And basically I'm asking you what does
that distance it has moved and if you
remember anything at all
from what I did earlier,
it's approximately this arc length, which
we have seen is our times delta theta.
In
other words, if you applied for SAF
and you rotate the body bay data,
the distance you actually
move is our Delta Theta.
So this is force times distance.
No, that's got to be equal.
The change in Kennedy Energy,
it's gotta be equal attendant.
Kinetic energy, kinetic energy.
I remind you is one half I will make a
square that for the change in Kennedy
Energy is going to be one half I femmes
Omega squared minus the initial Omega
Square.
By the way,
these are two very
enabling instance in time.
If the neighboring instance in time,
during that brief period,
we may take the body to
have a constant acceleration
that for Alpha is constant.
So this are this formula.
You can also calculate when alphas
constant period in a real body,
when there's rotating
alphanine not be constant,
but for the small enough interval,
as small as you wish,
we may have played the formula that works
when Alpha is a constant. In that case,
you would write it as one half times
to Alpha Times rotation angles,
right? Look at this formula here.
I'm referring to this rezone.
We'll make a final square minus Omega
initiative squared is two times Alpha
Times the change in angle.
So I want you to then
equate this work done,
this change in Kennedy Energy. I want
you to equate this guy, this guy,
and we get our great results that
f times R is equal to I find Alpha
I alpha is m a that's what I'm
looking for. So this Fella here,
Fr is the analog of force
and it's called the torque.
It's very important to notice that the
torque due to this force is the value of
the force times the distance
from the point of rotation
and it's only the external
force that I'm talking about.
They're also internal forces in Iraq.
Every part of the art is being dragged
along the way. Another part of the Rod.
But uh, that analysis in
terms of forces can be done,
but it's very tricky and complicated.
It's much easier to look at the energy
where the energy changes only due to
external forces. If you only look
at forces, you've got to be careful.
This pivot point is also
playing a force on the right,
but it's not moving
and not doing any work.
So the only external force is the one
I'm applying and Andrew's responsible for
the change of the Kennedy energy that
our other forces inside the rock.
In other words,
this mass is going to pick up speed.
Not because I'm directly pushing it.
I'm probably pushing this part of the rod
and that's putting the part next to it
and the propagates and the
finally pushes this one.
So I'm not directly applying
the force lot of this mass.
I'm saying whatever has happening
internally, I don't care.
The external force times distance is a
chain of the kinetic energy of an object.
Yes.
Good.
No,
I said this quantity,
the chains and Kennedy.
Kennedy is the final candidate going
to do one half Iomega square minus the
initial candidate energy
with final initial refer to
when the rod was there and
the and the Rod.
I rotated by a small amount.
Right? Okay. All right.
[inaudible]
here. No, I use this equation, the chain,
the Omega squared at the end minus the
Omega squared at the beginning is two
times the acceleration in
angular acceleration times data,
minor state or not is the change
in data over that time. Right?
In other words,
that formula can be used for even
finite PDFs of time provided Alpha is
constant. We're applying it
for a tiny period of time,
small enough for us to believe that the
acceleration during that tiny period is
some number alpha. So this Omega squared
men who make an r squared, is it really?
If you want a change in Omega squared
and that's proportional to Alpha Times of
change in angle.
So Alpha is not a constant ow fucking
Vaidy from incident to incident.
But at that one instance,
depending on the forces,
that will be some Alpha and this
thing called park. Is it times alpha?
Now,
I think it's very clear that if I had
several forces acting on the body than the
torque will be.
F I R I and that's just one
final caveat to this thing.
One final qualification,
which is that in practice,
the forces that I used to rotate the
body may not always be perpendicular.
You can apply a force in some
other directions like that.
Now you got to realize that park is the
ability to change the rotation state of
a body and what video is realizing is
that it depends on the force you apply and
depends on how far away the
forces from the point of rotation.
So if you have a door, you're trying
to open a door, here's the door,
you enter the hinges and you want to
open this door by applying a force.
The question is where do you put the door?
Not Okay.
You suddenly invented the door,
you thought about hinges,
but you haven't quite figured
out where to put the door,
not you got to ask yourself,
well, I have complete freedom.
It'll look nice,
but put it there right next to the hinges.
Then you realize that there are parts of
the universe like more on land where if
you go all the hinges, all the door
knobs that here and they're saying,
you know we are applying a lot of force,
we're not getting anywhere. What's wrong?
Well, what we are realizing
is that various forces,
everything in linear motion forced to
not everything in rotational motion.
You want to get your money's worth.
You got to take the door knob as far
as you can and put it near the end.
Okay. Then you figured that out. Then
you come along and you say, okay,
I put the door knobs at the
right place to open the door.
Then you are playing enormous force
this way and again frustrated again,
you're getting no results.
He said,
I'm going as far as they can from the
hinge and and it dawns on you that if you
really want to get something going,
you should really take the line of
separation between where it's rotating and
where you're applying the force
and a force perpendicular to
any part parallel to it. It's not doing
anything unless you try to rip it off.
The hinges, you don't
want to do that. So here,
this force has got a useless part and
the guard or useful part and the useful
part,
they useless part,
which is trying to pull the rod off
the hinges is going to be balanced by a
force from the hinges because they're
artists that really draw is not going to
move,
but the one perpendicular to the rod can
in fact turn the rod without affecting
the rigidity.
So we need an extra factor here,
which is sine theta I but Taita
is defined as the follows.
If you are at a point our eye and
you are play force F that way,
Theta is the angle between the line
joining the point of application of the
force and the direction of the force.
You are here and you're separated by
this vector and there's the angle between
the separation vector and the force
that angle theta can vary from force to
force.
For this force F I angle could be data I,
that's the final formula for the torque.
Okay,
so we have built up all the pieces
and this is the final answer.
This is the definition of Torque and
with this torque we can now complete the
dictionary and say what we want in
the left hand side is the torque with
metronic is defined as f. I. R.
I signed data I
f signed data.
It's just a component of the force
perpendicular to the separation are.
That's what Fci data does.
I hope you can see that you've
got a force acting this way,
f course sine theta as this part, which
is no good and that scientists that part,
which is good photo rotations.
Also
if you want in terms of work done,
you want the force times
the distance traveled.
Distance traveled is
only in this direction.
There is no distance traveled
in this direction, so the
distance traveled, yes, f.
Dot.
Product with the bad action in which you
move and that applies only to the force
pat perpendicular to the separation
knocked to the part that is parallel.
Anyway,
I hope you understand intuitively why
this is the guy that's responsible for
rotating objects. Do you want to
rotate something? I don't. Some axes.
You've got a certain amount of force.
You're best off applying the force as far
as you can from the point of rotation.
In other words, suppose we want
to rearrange the stable here,
keeping this and fixed but want
to turn it so it's this way.
Then I'm saying I think we all know
we want to start pushing here also.
We don't want that play
force this way or that way.
We want to play force perpendicular.
If for some reason we get tied to a rope
and can only pull in that direction,
then the component of the force,
this ways to be discounted, no use.
This is the part that does the training
and that's why that's the part that also
does the work.
Any forest perpendicular,
the motion is not going to do any
work is the fourth protection.
Any force [inaudible] nickel, that
displacement is not going to do any work.
This rigid body can only
be later in that position.
So that displacement is in a tangential
direction and only the force in a
tangential direction contributes to the
work. And in my work energy argument,
that's what comes in.
This is the reason why you come
up with this definition of torque.
Okay, so we've got, uh,
most of the pieces for this,
I will write one more thing by analogy.
The work done by a force that
displaces a body for animal dx is this,
the work done by a torque
will be towel times.
I think you can guess what I want to
put there by Ams d theta or Delta data.
When a torque rotates a body,
but angle Delta Theta,
then the work done is
tout times delta data.
You can see that even here
you can write the word down as
F Times r team, Delta Theta.
But that is the torque.
That's the Delta t.
So it's very useful to know. So if you
guys are going to reason by analogy,
I would ask you to know the counterparts
only then you can do the problems.
So let's take a,
let's get used to this formula here.
Delta W, Star, Delta Theta
show you one example.
Suppose I have a rod hanging
from the ceiling. Well,
let's saves massless and there is a mass
Emma at the bottom and it's got some
length l.
It's a pendulum.
I'm going to take this pendulum and
I'm going to bring it to this position
by an angle data, not just
the unfortunately paid
or not here at Stanford.
The final angle,
I want to know how much work I do.
That's what we're going to calculate,
so be it takes that intermediate position.
When we add here,
what does the force acting on this guy?
This rod is massless the forest on this.
This AMG.
Okay.
If that angle is data,
you can see that bangle is the same paper,
empty core sine theta acts this way
and MD signed data acts that way.
The whole the pendulum from
falling when the angel is data,
I have to apply a tangential force
in this direction of size Mt.
St Theater.
I hope you guys can see that
the empty coal sine data is going to
be provided by the Rod because rod is a
rigid body. It won't let the mass move
in this direction. It'll provide water,
would force it takes to keep the mass
moving radially in the tangential
direction to keep it from
sliding back to where it began.
I have to apply force mg sine data,
so the torque that apply
is mg sine theta times l,
so I did all that by taking the force,
finding the component of
the forest perpendicular to
the thing and balancing it
with the countervailing force. You can
equally say the park that I have to apply,
it's really mg,
which is the force odd,
which happens to be l here and
sine of the angle between them.
No matter how you write it,
that's the torque.
Let's find the work done by that torque.
When I rotated from the starting
angle to some final angle,
that'll be m g l signed data,
deep data from zero to
some final angle data, not,
I'm just saying the word done stout
dealt at data summed over all the angles
that means integrate.
So you've got to go back to your calculus
thing and you got to remember that the
integral of scientists minus goes signed
data and you want to start from theta
equals zero that they take to
some final angle to it or not.
And if you crank it out you will find
there's AMG l times one minus go sign in
theater. So that's the work done to
take a pendulum which is horizontal,
which is vertical and turn
it into an angle. Taylor. Now
I'm going to do a cross check on this to
tell you that it works out from another
point of view. This mass was down
here. No, it's claimed that there.
So you can ask what
happened to the work I did.
Going back to work entity Theorem,
let's take this mass here.
Forces are acting on it.
One was the rod,
but the force of the artist
always perpendicular to the
motion of this Bob here.
So it couldn't do any work.
They only work was done by me.
What happened to the work did work I did
has to be changing the total energy of
the body,
but the Bob was not moving before and
it's not moving after because I give just
the right force to cancel gravity.
I didn't give it any speed.
So it must be that the potential energy
of this Bob and his here should explain
the work I did. That's exactly
what it is because let me rewrite.
This is AMG
minus MGL.
Let me see a plus
MTL co signed data.
Okay,
well maybe we can see that. Uh, it is mg,
sorry plus MGL
this one.
Well I think it's best to write it as
l minus Elko scientist and you guys can
see what's going on Ellis.
This distance here. Elko,
sine theta is that distance in l minus
Elko send data is the increase in the
height of this Bob.
This height here is in fact l minus Elko
scientists because of that is l that is
data.
This is Elko signed data to that point.
So this is just mg times the height
and that's where your work went.
So what's the point of this exercise?
This exercise is to get you used to
the notion of calculating work done,
not as forced time distance,
but a star times angle.
And here's the problem where the torque
itself is changing with the angle.
The torque is of cell function of data.
So you have to do an integral
and that's how you get work.
Okay,
so now we've got all
the machinery we need,
got all the machinery we need to do
kinematics and dynamics of rigid bodies in
this analogy. So let me summarize
what it is. Got a rigid body.
He's got a moment of inertia.
It's got an angular velocity.
The product of the two is called the
angular momentum l. And to change it,
you gotta play a Torque.
The find the Torque Pine,
all the external forces acting on the
body multiplay each force by the distance
from the point of rotation
or the component of each
force perpendicular to the
line of separation times
that distance and separation.
That's the Fr scientists ETA and added up.
Again,
when you do the torques
you've got to give it a sign.
If at tar trends to rotate
a body counterclockwise,
we will take it as positive and if the
tart tends rotator body clockwise we'll
take it as negative.
So it's possible that in a given body
that could be torques trying to move it in
different directions.
So for example in the simplest rigid body
made up say two masses,
you could be pushing this way
and I could be pushing that way.
You're all trying to rotate them in
opposite directions. The park you apply,
it would be your fourth time.
That distance,
this is called positive because you're
going counterclockwise torque that I'm
applying will be my fourth time to smaller
distance and there'll be considered
negative because it's clockwise
and you will add them up.
You'll get a net torque.
That net torque will cause an
acceleration of this dumbbell like object.
What acceleration will it cause?
It'll be my force times,
my distance scientist.
I have habits we want minus your force
times the distance over which you're
doing it times a moment to finish up
the moment of furniture for the simple
problem is m one or one square
plus m two r two squared.
If this is m one and this is our one and
this is m two and that distance is art
too.
So this is the simplest problem you
could do in rigid body dynamics.
Take a couple of forces,
workout the torques divided by a
moment of inertia and get the angular
acceleration. If the Torque is a
constant, it's hard to maintain that.
What do I have to do to
keep the torque constant?
I got to start running around with this
acid rotates and you could imagine doing
that. Then the target will be constantly,
Alpha will be constant alpha constantly.
It's like a constant and you can do the
whole bunch of problems you guys did
before. Okay? Now that is one
technical obstacle you've got overcome
if you want to do rigid body dynamics.
And that is to know how to compute
the moment of inertia for all kinds of
objects.
If I give you 37 masses,
eat with the distance r
from the point of rotation,
it's a trivial thing to Mr
squared for each one and add it.
But here's the kind of
objects you may be given.
Not a discreet set of masters
but a continuous blood.
Just like in the case of center of mass,
when he had a bunch of masters,
you took em one x one plus m two x
two plus m three x three and so on.
But if you had a rod, which is
continuous, you have to do an integral.
So you will have to do an integral here.
All right,
so let's take certain rigid bodies and
tried to find that moment of inertia,
which are rigid bodies
which are continuous.
So here is a ring of
radius r and mass amp.
It's not a disc in spite
of what it looks like,
it is a ring and I want to find her.
It's moment of inertia.
You have to think about what you will do.
So you think for a second and I'll
tell you the way I will do that is to
partition it into tiny pieces into which
is small enough for me to consider a
point.
This tiny piece has a Mass Delta
am I and I goes from one, two,
three, four to whatever 10
million they go around the circle.
Want me to finish? Yeah. Would be,
I use Delta Mia to tell you it's
a tiny mass for this section,
but what is the r square?
If I plan it to rotate it around that
point plan to rotate around that point,
it is the same artist squared for
everybody so you can pull it out of the
summation and he'd just get Mr Square.
So this is a bit easy problem.
This as easy as this problem.
Then you clearly had only one mass and
all of it was that distance r from the
point of rotation is Mr squared
here you got the mass spread out.
Luckily spit it out,
spit it out in such a way that every
part of it is the same distance out from
the center.
So it's very easy to do the summation,
pull out the arch where do the sum
over mass and get the total Max.
Then we are going to do
any question about this.
Everything's going to be built on
understanding this. So for the ring,
this is the moment of
inertia with just Mr Square,
but now I want to do the following.
I want to take a disc now.
Yeah,
of radius R
I got her to the summer but Mr
squares for every mass in the problem.
So he here's where do you have
to organize your thinking?
I'm plan to do the moment of furniture
through the center. First of all,
if he didn't tell you all my to finish
it through where you cannot even start,
I tell you I want it through the
center that wanted through the center.
We have the ability then to think of
this as made up of a whole bunch of
concentric rings,
each one at radius r and a thickness.
Dr
If it can find the moment of an
issue of this tiny shaded region.
I some over all this certain,
all the little washers that
annual assist and you like that.
I have to fill up the whole disk.
What's the moment of inertia
of this Angeles? Well,
I already told you if the analyst has
a mass m Mr squared is the moment of
Finnish. Yeah. Of the analysts,
but so the question is what does
the mass of the shaded region,
clearly the r squared to use is
the audit which it is sitting,
but what's the mass I should
use for the mass I should use?
I argue that if the total mass is that
that time is Pi r square is the mass per
unit area than I need the
area of this shaded region.
That's the tricky part. If
you've got that. Yes. Right.
So let's ask why it's two Pi r d.
R.
If you take this analyst and you take a
pair of scissors and you cut it out and
you open it out,
he's going to look like a long rectangle.
It's thickness will be the
R is length will be to PR.
So two Pi r d r is the,
yeah,
that's as contribution.
Here's the Dr and have you got
to add it up over everything?
Adding it up is what we
do by doing the integral.
I don't want to do this integral,
you guys can.
We can at least guess
what's going to happen.
There's going to be no pie in the answer.
Why is gone.
We've got our r squared is r cubed r to
the fourth of our four and that will,
if you combine it with that you
get this Mr squared over two.
So more matter of finesse you
often discuss Mr squared over two.
That's because if I came and told
you woman definitely supports,
they made a calculation mistake
somewhere and I said is Mr Square?
We'll you know I'm wrong and why would
he argue that cannot be the right answer.
Yes.
Well it's like the brain but the radius.
Smaller group, right? In other words,
this answers correct answer
is if it does Mr Square,
it means the entire mass is
that the designs are square,
but we know some of the masters a
lot closer to the center. In fact,
some of fitness right at the center,
so you cannot get the same capital r
squared as a contribution from all the
pieces. Some will be at zero distance.
I will be at the full distance.
So whenever at the moment
of inertia for disk,
it's gotta look like Mr
Squared Times a number,
which is definitely less than one.
Turns out to be half.
If you've got a third or a fourth,
you will know it's obviously wrong.
But if I got one in front or where
civic art two times Mr Square,
then you know I made a mistake.
Okay.
Now the last of the objects I
want to look at today is a rod.
I want to take
this actually the example
that's done quite often,
but that's the first example.
But I will do it now. So here,
this
eight Rod.
Okay,
that's length l
mass m and I say,
what's the moment of inertia?
You know what you could do?
What's the first question you will ask?
When I say,
what's the moment of an issue?
I don't work point right till I tell you
that you cannot begin. So I will say,
let's find a moment of inertia.
I the sense of what you
should imagine in that case,
you stick a nail through here and the
guy who rotates like that on a big circle
with that as the center, if you
start the nail through the mid point,
it's a different story.
The answer's different.
So here what I do is I take a distance ex,
I take a sliver of thickness dx.
That's sliver the small enough for me to
consider it as a point mass. Therefore,
the moment of an issue of that tiny
portion will look like the square of the
distance times the mass of the tiny
portion mass. The tiny portion,
it looks like this.
Let me see. Ah, that's the mass.
But unit length, that's the length.
That's the mass of the object. Then I
have to do the integral from zero to l.
Well x squared will give me x cubed over
three that'll give me an l square over
three.
That's the moment to finish you off the
ride. Again, it looks like ml square.
It's got to have a number in front of it.
That's less than one because
if you're mentioning from here,
the furthest you can be is l a
lot of the guys had a lot closer,
so the weighted average of the square of
the distance cannot be all in squared.
It's gotta be something
less than elsewhere.
The fact that it's one third is of
course what you do all the work for.
Pardon me?
You forgot the l here.
Also,
the dimension for moment of inertia
should be in the end mass times length
square.
You're not happy with that.
You agree? Okay, look,
sometimes I do get these things wrong,
so you should always try
to keep an eye on this.
The last thing I want
to do is to find the,
okay,
but when I say last thing I want to do,
I don't mean I'm reluctant to do it.
I'm just saying I'm
near the end of the day.
The final thing that I will now calculate
is the moment of inertia around the
center.
Let's see what's going to happen.
It's the same integral x
where the x over l m over l,
but the range of integration for x will
love go from minus l over to the plus l
or two.
Then I simplify my life by writing it
as two m over l times x squared DX from
zero to l over to, this is something
I encourage you to do all the time.
If an integral isn't
even function at Beck's,
namely negative x contributes
as much as positive x,
then you can take half the reason of
integration and double the answer.
You can do it only if it's an
even function. So excellent. Yes.
Oh, I'm sorry. You're absolutely right.
The way to do that would be here.
So you keep trying. You will catch
me. That's right. That's correct.
Okay,
so let's do this now to m over l.
Okay. Uh, now I'm really
anxious because this l l cube,
it's the x cubed over three.
But the thing that's
been cubed as l over too
and that's giving me ml square over 12
so the moment of inertia is not a
fixed number. It got a lot smaller.
When I took it around the center of mass,
when I took it around the left edge,
I got ml squared over three
I went to the midpoint,
I got ml square or well I think it's
pretty clear that in going from here I
reduced the answer. You might
say, why not keep going?
Maybe we'll get even smaller.
That's where your common sense should
tell you that if you got some answer from
there,
you're going to get the same answers
from here and you hit the best possible
moment of inertia.
You can.
You should be able to do argue
intuitively and if you do the calculation,
it will come out to be the same.
Now the thing to check,
if you do this,
the moment of financial are on one end
is the moment of inertia around the
center,
less the mass times l over to square.
This is something you can actually verify.
Just take the numbers I gave you and you
will find that this answer plus m times
l over to square will be equal to that
answer and this happens to be very
general theater and I'll talk about next
time if you know the moment I finish
here through the center of mass,
you're done.
Because if I want the moment of
inertia through any other point,
I take the moment of inertia through the
center of mass and add to it the total
mass of the object and the square of the
distance by which you made me move my
access,
which here happens to be l over too.
I haven't of course proved this. I don't
want to give you anything without proof.
We can actually in our class actually
satisfy ourself to this is true.
Not only is it true for a rod,
it's even true for a disc.
It's true for any object in two dimensions
that if you've got the moment of
inertia of this creature through the
center of mass and you wanted through that
point, just take the answer to center
of mass and add to it AMD square.
Where is that?
This that'll be proven next time.